excuse me sorry for that pause we have
the verdict now we have a guilty verdict
on five well there you go of the six
charges
on count one guilty that's conspiracy to
entice an individual under the age of 17
to travel in interstate commerce with
intent to engage in illegal sexual
activity that was the most that was the
five years in prison count two this is
the not guilty enticement of an
individual under the age of 17 to travel
with intent to engage in illegal sexual
activity say maximum five years so
guilty of conspiracy
not guilty of the enticement itself and
then counts three four five and six are
all guilty conspiracy to transport
individuals under the age of 17 a minor
to travel in interstate commerce with
intent to engage in illegal sexual
activity transportation of an individual
under the age of 17 with intent to
engage in illegal sexual activity
sex trafficking conspiracy and sex
trafficking of an individual under the
age of 18 a minor count six that brings
with it a maximum of 40 years in prison
galaine maxwell found guilty on five of
her six federal charges tonight five of
the six means she could face a total
of 65 years in prison that's galaine
maxwell on your screen right now that
tonight was found guilty by a federal
jury on five of six counts including
transportation of an individual under
the age of 17 with intent to engage in
illegal sexual activity
in sex trafficking and in sex
trafficking conspiracy
jason chaffetz your thoughts on this
five of six guilty verdict return there
you know the the best belief i have in
the justice system is the jury and and
the jury listened to it uh they came to
this conclusion and hallelujah i there
are a lot of women
who went through hell and i hope they
feel some sense of justice i don't think
it'll ever make up for the hideous
nature and wishes which was done uh that
what jeffrey epstein and ms maxwell did
is just one of the most disgusting
things you can imagine for these young
women but i'm glad she's going to
essentially spend the rest of her life
in jail
and i hope that it is it is a good hope
for those that have suffered these types
of injustices that have been
have been assaulted uh whether it's by
themselves in an alley or whatever it
might be
that justice can prevail it's hard for
these women i can't even imagine what
it's like to come forward and have to
testify i hope the 100 or so that didn't
testify are able to uh speak or sh or
show the judge uh and talk to the judge
uh in the in the
in the sentencing phase uh if they want
to come forward and talk about this but
there's also a lot more to this story
this guy didn't get prosecuted earlier
and it seemed like he probably should
have and there were a lot of other
people that were complicit and if the
federal government's going to do their
job they need to go after those people
as well
all right for more on this developing
case let's go to alexis mcadams our
reporter outside the federal courthouse
in new york city right now alexis
emily that's right we've been waiting
here for several days standing by for
any developments today it was so quiet
the judge had told that jury she wanted
them to stick around at least through
six o'clock today due to major coveted
concerns she wanted to move things along
as quick as possible without pushing
them too much and they did come to a
decision just in the past 20 minutes or
so as you all just read guilty galen
maxwell and five out of six counts here
that coming out of that federal
courthouse behind me just moments ago as
we go through those six counts guilty on
all of them except for count two which
as we know is enticing a minor to travel
to engage in illegal sex acts which
carries a maximum sentence of five years
in prison that was the charge that those
jurors in that room even asked for a
white board some markers and
highlighters as they went and asked the
judge to please clarify what enticement
meant on those charges and this comes
after about 40 hours of deliberations
today on day six that verdict finally
coming out here the judge telling the
jurors that with that astronomical spike
in covet cases in new york she wanted
things to move along she was worried
that one of those jurors was going to
have to go into quarantine which would
definitely disrupt the trial the jury
did have several questions just today
there was about a few notes that were
sent out as well but in the past during
those deliberations including the
holiday break that happened they had
asked 13 questions to the judge sending
out those notes asking for more
testimony asking to see some more of
that evidence so it was
a lot of us out here wondering if it was
going to happen especially because they
ended yesterday around five o'clock when
she asked them to stay an extra hour
saying hey you think we're in a good
spot we're gonna head home for the night
and the jurors still had a lot of
questions even though today prosecutors
telling them that she had groomed and
trafficked underage girls to be sexually
abused by her former boyfriend jeffrey
epstein and after that long holiday
weekend they came back asking for the
testimony from all four accusers and
wanting the judge once again to clarify
that definition of enticement the jurors
were deliberating for hours but finally
coming out and we had so many people
that were on the channel as well talking
about and legal experts saying as the
time continued to pass emily they were
saying well this could be good for the
defense because it looks like you know
they were having a lot of questions
still at this point but that jury making
the decision here after 40 hours of
delay deliberations rather in manhattan
inside of that federal court guilty
elaine maxwell now and five out of six
charges
alexis thank you for that wrap up and i
wanted to uh circle back with you on one
thing that you mentioned so as the jury
asked questions during their
deliberative process they kept asking
questions one of the transcripts that
they asked for was that of the quote
memory expert that defense brought this
is a famous psychological expert
testimony witness that is testified in
every trial from o.j simpson to bill
cosby and ted
bundy fred durst what was the tenor when
the jury came back and asked for that
transcript in the courtroom and amongst
the pool of reporters did people expect
a verdict that might not go the way that
it went tonight alexis
yeah i think it just depends you know on
who you ask and how long people were in
there just watching things move along
but that was really interesting that was
the first time they had asked for
testimony and transcripts of the
defense's witness that came today and as
you mentioned that expert said that when
people go through trauma
that they can sometimes remember things
even though they're very vivid
as completely different than really what
happened so when they did ask for that
today i'm sure many people in the
courtroom and people have been watching
this case from all over the country and
all over the world emily thought how are
things going to play out here but guilty
right now galen maxwell coming out of
that federal court just moments ago we
also saw her family members showing up
here and i don't know if you can see too
much over my shoulder here but as we
mentioned it was silent out here i mean
media people are sitting in their cars
just waiting and waiting and then all of
a sudden when we obviously heard that
there was a verdict people were all over
the place and that's when we saw the
maxwell family as well
alexis thank you so much for that we are
now going to bring in former justice
department prosecutor jim trustee who
joins us there jim thank you for joining
us right now tell us your thoughts top
line on maxwell being guilty on five of
her six federal charges tonight
i think a couple of things emily i mean
the first is that even though this took
a while and the jury had a lot of
questions they struck me as being a
cohesive group you know they were asking
questions it sounded like they were very
comfortable methodically plowing through
the evidence and hearing each other out
there was really no sign of them being
deadlocked or struggling from the
outside so
i'm not totally shocked that we had a
verdict today the other thing is you
know what drives the sentencing in the
federal system is not going to be the
maximum penalty or even the exact
constellation of charges it's going to
be the sentencing guidelines and when i
do just a very quick kind of cocktail
napkin uh review of the guidelines it's
very quick to get them up to an offense
level of 34 which translates to about 12
and a half to 15 and a half years of
non-parole time
as a guideline you know for these
offenses and it could get higher than
that so she's looking at a weighty
sentence there's gonna be a lot of
fighting about those guidelines but it's
gonna be pretty inescapable that it's
gonna it should carry a lot of time
jim it's it's um i mean humorous is not
the right word but when you talk about
that she's facing 65 years but
practically speaking it's only 12. i
mean that seems not a lot for the weight
the gravitas of these six federal
charges that she was found guilty of
that include enticing minors across
state lines to engage in illegal sexual
criminal acts do you think that that
sentence would seem disappointing after
again the weight of these five guilty
counts
yeah i mean the guidelines are just the
starting point they're not the end point
anymore like they used to be in the old
days so there's room for a judge to vary
upwards to go higher up and one of the
things that struck me about this trial
and one of the things i think was
important to the jury was that the
enticement was not literally just
enticement persuasion you know talking
the the testimony of the women about her
role in the offense included her
sexually abusing them so it was a very
active very aggressive very criminal
level of culpability that miss maxwell
had beyond just enticement that's the
type of thing that can aggravate the
sentence that allows the judge to go
higher but again we fall into the trap
of talking about maximum penalties like
that's always the starting point and it
rarely is so i think you're going to
look at a weighty sentence but probably
not something to the tune of 50 or 60
years jason chaffetz has a question for
you jim
sure
jim what did you obviously the
prosecutors have to be pleased getting
uh five of the six counts uh to get to a
guilty but what did you think of the
strategy by the prosecutors to only
bring four of the victims i know there
are 24 witnesses but the actual victims
themselves it seemed like a bit of a
risky strategy but maybe obviously i you
know given the verdict the prosecutors
would say they made the right decision
yeah i mean it's always easy afterwards
right to announce that we were
definitely
the smartest people in the room but look
i think it's a great question i think
there's a little bit of a a turning
point a point of diminishing returns and
you know we have this issue with the
cosby trial too like how many victims
are going to be allowed in and the key
is multiple victims are certainly
self-bolstering they make the case a lot
easier for the government when it's not
simply one person giving a a story like
this so four certainly seem to work well
here the other thing i would just tell
you from a defense perspective when you
get into
dozens of witnesses testifying about
similar incidents there's room for
inconsistencies it may not be anything
nefarious it may just be that they have
different memories different abilities
to perceive things but even the the
blind squirrel starts finding a nut when
you get up to 10 or 15 or 20 witnesses
talking about the same thing they will
discover inconsistencies to argue
reasonable doubt to the jury when you
get that kind of high number of
witnesses
jim we have a statement of u.s attorney
damien williams on this verdict which
reads a unanimous jury has found galen
maxwell guilty of one of the worst
crimes imaginable facilitating and
participating in the sexual abuse of
children crimes that she committed with
her longtime partner and co-conspirator
jeffrey epstein the road to justice has
been far too long but today justice has
been done i want to commend the bravery
of the girls now grown women who stepped
out of the shadows and into the
courtroom their courage and willingness
to face their abuser made this case and
today's result possible i also want to
thank the career prosecutors of the
southern district of new york who
embraced the victim's quest for justice
and have worked tirelessly day in and
day out to ensure that maxwell was held
accountable for her crimes this office
will always stand with victims will
always follow the facts wherever they
lead and will always fight to ensure
that no one no matter how powerful and
well connected is above the law that was
a statement of u.s attorney damien
williams on the verdict in the galen
maxwell case gym and
what's interesting about that is that it
reflects squarely on the culpability and
accountability of gelane maxwell herself
as you said she participated herself
physically in the in the abuse it's part
of the insidious nature of the
enticement and what was encapsulated
within that and that begs the larger
question that jason brought up earlier
which was do you see any type of of um
additional work to prosecute to go after
those others who were complicit or do
you see
that the the buck stops on her shoulders
will the public be able to look forward
to more being held accountable or do you
see it ending now here today jim
yeah that's a great crystal ball
question emily i don't know is the short
answer but look i will tell you this a
lot of career prosecutors that i know
that have specialized in child abuse or
sex offense cases are very keen on going
after the johns as well as they call it
the men that participated in the sexual
acts with these young women or sometimes
children and so yeah the natural
tendency for a prosecutor is to keep
going and frankly there's even a
possibility of maxwell still cooperating
partly because she didn't testify and
and complicate things by perjuring
herself so there is still room for the
investigation to roll forward to try to
tie in some maybe very high profile
individuals that hung out with epstein
at orgy island and
we'll have to take a wait and see maybe
they've been trying that maybe they've
already resigned themselves to this
being the end game there's certainly a
high level of culpability for miss
maxwell but it is a shame if they walk
away from the possibility of pursuing
other people too
johnny joey jones do you have a question
for jim
yeah jim you know you kind of just hit
on exactly what i wanted to ask about
not being a lawyer of any kind myself
i've kind of been relegated to
interpreting documentaries and now what
we've seen about this
trial play out but i guess you know my
biggest question is you do have a lot of
high profile individuals who have been
either outright accused like prince
andrew or or kind of brought into the
public eye on this and i guess my
question is once sentencing happened say
it is a 50-year sentence could that does
she still have the opportunity to i
guess turn evidence and testify against
others to reduce our sentence or does
this guilty verdict kind of solidify
whatever that sentence becomes
yeah that's a great question and look
there's still a mechanism under the
federal rules uh to to actually allow
for a reduction of sentence based on
cooperation federal rule of criminal
procedures 35 and some offices use it
more frequently than others some offices
might say hey she went to trial we're
done with her
but other times because she didn't
testify they they might at least
entertain
having a profit where they sit down and
listen to her and see what she might be
able to do in terms of moving an
investigation forward so legally the
mechanism is still there it's really a
question of the of the prosecutors in
the u.s attorney's office in southern
district of new york whether they've
already had any sort of proffers with
her which we don't know that were failed
or if they are willing to listen or
again if she's even willing to do it so
there's a bunch of ifs but practically
there's at least a possibility that at
some point after her sentencing she
would be a government witness and would
be looking at a potential for some sort
of reduction in that sentence
jim leslie has a question for you leslie
marshall
hi jim i had two questions actually
jason asked my first about the victims
but secondly to the victims
as a victim of sex crimes i always look
at
situations like this
being a positive and making it easier
for people in the future to come forward
for those that feel that they're going
to be victimized again or demonized by
defense and that the system won't work
and that it'll be a waste of time can
you speak to that briefly
yeah that's a great point i mean and
look i've handled as a prosecutor back
in the day i certainly handled sex
offense cases not of the profile of this
type of case and you always had this
dynamic of reluctance sometimes
compounded by cultural divides language
divides you know intelligence issues all
sorts of things that make these very
tough cases
and i have to say that it is there's no
such thing as perfect closure uh you
know these victims are still carrying
scars that they'll carry for the rest of
their days but there is something about
the reversal of power that's a good
thing you know when the people that are
sitting in the defendant's chair have to
sweat out the powerful testimony of
these long victimized young women
it's a great moment so i hope that it
has that kind of universal effect i
don't know if there's any way to
perfectly measure this but it is a good
message that again the criminal justice
system for all of its flaws for all of
its imperfections it can get it right a
lot and in a case like this to know that
in the highest of profile cases that
these victims were listened to believed
and supported these convictions that's a
good moment
jim we have a question for you from
tyrus
uh you know
hey how are you jim you know it's
one of the things that popped in my head
because i think the word conspiracy is
uh really apropos because it was she
conspired to set up these things and was
a willing participant and i think that
was a slam dunk for the prosecution one
of the things that does concern me in
this new era of pandemics and covet
effect i keep hearing the judge was
concerned about kovid he was concerned
about a breakout was concerned about a
juror is there a leg for an appeal here
saying the jury was rushed that they
would try to push something like that
that kovid caused the jury not to look
at all the facts long enough for her can
you see something like this start to
happen in our in our courtrooms
yeah i mean look i think the appeal is
going to be uphill when it comes to
managing the jury and their
deliberations you're talking about an
abuse of discretion standard which means
the judge the trial judge has to really
do something pretty bad to get reversed
on appeal but you know the timing of
this is interesting in that she
basically let them know hey guys you
know i'd rather you stay longer because
you know covet is on the horizon we
might have some problems with you and
you're going to have to sit through new
year's eve new year's day all of a
sudden we get a verdict so it's going to
make its way into the defense brief i
would think but that doesn't really give
it enough
enough legs to necessarily win so yeah
there's always an issue when it comes to
things like jury selection and also the
deliberations and decisions about
whether or not the jury is sequestered
uh i think this could make its way into
a brief but i don't think it's going to
be all that powerful to the circuit
jim trustee thank you as always for your
amazing expertise we appreciate it good
talking to you guys